ميسون نحن نتابع من قصه الى اخرى ولكن نقف
على هذه البنايه حكايتها يعني حكايه
بصراحه اطلب من الزميل المصور ان يقترب
معي هذه البنايه لا تزال هنالك عشره
عائلات تحت الانقاض لم يتم الوصول اليها
بعد ميسون اليوم صباحا اخرجوا تسع اشخاص
احدهم كان على قيد الحياه والان تبقى عشره
عائلات كانت هذه البنايه كانت مكونه من
ثمان طبقات
وفي داخل هذه البنايه ايضا تسكن تسكن
عائلات سوريه وانا ساتحدث الان ان سمحت لي
ميسون مع احد الاشخاص الذي ينتظر الكشف عن
مصير اقربائه تحت هذه البنايه تحياتي لك
بس لو ننظر الى الكاميرا من فضلك اتعرف
عليك
كامله وفي ابن خالي وعائلته كمان كم عددهم
تقريبا
لحد الان خبر عنهم والناس بيقولوا اخذوها
على المشفى وناس بيقولوا كذا بس لحد الان
تحت الانقاذه لا وحاولنا نصرح عليهم
الامام ومن الخلف ومن كل الجهات انت حاولت
تدخل تحكيهم
الى الان احاول لم اسمع اي صوت طب متى كان
اخر تواصل معهم اي شيء يعني اي شيء
بتعرفوه متى كم عدد المتواجدين كم عدد
اللي كانوا بره لما صار اثناء الزلزال كما
تشاهد يعني
قطع صوته من اثناء الزندال تحدثنا
المنقذين لفرق الانقاذ ايش حكوا لك ايش
ايش قالوا لي انه اليوم استخرجوا شخص على
قيد الحياه على قدامي اخرج شخص وقتل ضحايا
طالعوها من فوق وفي شخص مشوه بالنص
للاسف
ويعني الوضع كتير كتير ماشا الضحايا ما
بتطلع مثل ما هي عم تطلع شقف يعني اليوم
الى الطياره يعني وضع كتير ماساوي
للاسف طيب ايش طمنوكم انتم متى يصلوا الى
المكان اللي فيه شقق اي طابق هم كانوا
تحدثنا مع الدفاع المدني ان شاء الله يعني
يتموا للصباح لحتى ينهو هيدي المكان لانه
اكثر من عائله عم تشتكي عم تنتظر مثل ما
انا بنتظر
وبتمنى انه من الدفاع المدني يضم يستمر
لانه عم بصير فيه بعض التاثيرات انه من
وقت
ربما بسبب انه كثره المواقع والانهيارات
يعني لانه الفرق نعم بس ولكن انه هون 28
بيت يعني ما هو انه بيت بيتين يعني انا
سالت احد المنقذين يتحدث العربيه واكد لي
انه في عشر عائلات لا تزال تحت الانقاض ان
شاء الله نتمنى يعني ان يكونوا سالمين
ويعني تلقاهم سالمين بحول الله ميسون نحن
نتابع هذه القصه في الواقع ولكني سالتف
ايضا بالكاميرا الى الجهه المقابله لاسرد
لك قصه اخرى نتابعها ولكن من بعيد لانها
يعني هنالك حساسيه وخوف كبير من البنايه
التي
المجاهدينها الان عبر الكاميرا هذه
البنايه ميسون لم تنهار ولكنها سقطت في
الاسفل
بعمق التسويه وهنالك اشخاص ثلاث شباب
سوريين محاصرين داخل تسويه هذه البنايه
كان احد اقربائهم اتصل معهم واجاب احد
الاشخاص تحت الانقاظ على الهاتف واكد انه
على قيد الحياه وهذا كان امس الاتصال بعد
ذلك الهاتف يرن ولا يجيب وجاء فريق متخصص
اليوم ولديه اجهزه متطوره واكد ان هنالك
حياه لاشخاص تحت الانقاض ويعني من خلال
الاجهزه تبين ان هنالك من هو على قيد
الحياه وبالتالي عمليات حساسه جدا ان كانت
زميل يستطيع الدخول اكثر في الكاميرا الى
هناك هم يعرف اي اصعب يعني بالنسبه لرجال
الانقاذ ان يحاولوا ان يشيلوا الركام
ليجدوا من تحته او انه ببنايه مثل هذه او
هذا المبنى ان يحاول الوصول الى القاع
وخاصه انه ممكن فكره انهيار المبنى نفسه
تكون قائمه صحيح
بالتاكيد بالضبط يعني انا اكثر عمليه
انقاذ اراها حساسه هذه العمليه رغم ان
البنايه غير منهاره لانهم حذروا احنا كنا
اقتربنا للتصوير هناك وكان تحذير حازم جدا
انه لا لن لن يقف هناك سوى فرق الانقاذ
لانه في بعض رجال الانقاذ دخلوا بالفعل
على عمق امتار في تلك البنايه الان هم تحت
يحاولوا ان يدخلوا ويصلوا الى هؤلاء
الاشخاص العالقين وتحدثت من قبل بانه قصه
هؤلاء الشباب احدهم جاء من اسطنبول الى
هذه المدينه ليله الزلزال ميسون يعني
تمهيدا لكتب كتابه للزواج ولكنه للاسف
يعني هذا كان ما حدث معه انه تحت الانقاذ
المبنى متصدع اصلا
بدي اسال سؤال فيما يتعلق
بفرق الانقاذ لانه تحدثنا عن ارقام كبيره
خاصه في تركيا ومنهم من تطوع الى اي حد
هذه الفرق فعلا
لديها الكفاءه والتجربه
والمهاره في التعاطي مع مثل هذه الازمات
اولا يعني طبعا هم على مستوى عالي جدا من
الكفاءه وهذا واضح
زائد انه هنالك فرق انقاذ ليست فقط تركيا
يعني فريق الانقاذ الذي كشف بالجهاز
الحراري عن وجود احياء او وجود يعني حياه
تحت هذا المبنى كان فريق اردني مثلا
وهنالك فريق اخر من جنسيه غير تركيا تعمل
في نفس الموقع الان في يعني وهم الذين
طلبوا بطانيات قبل تقريبا نصف ساعه من
الان وبالتالي هنالك يعني متطوعين كثر
سواء من داخل تركيا او من خارج تركيا
يعملون بطاقه كبيره جدا بدقه كبيره جدا
ولكن ميسون السؤال الاهم انه لماذا هنالك
بعض البنايات مثلا التي لم تبدا حتى هذه
اللحظه فيها العمليات بشكل كبير اعطيك
مثالا سالتفت ايضا قليلا على بنايه اخرى
شاهدي في هذه البنايه ميسون في الكاميرا
ان كانت تظهر هذه البنايه مدمره بالكامل
وفيها عائلات كثيره حتى اللحظه تخيلي نحن
في اليوم الرابع العمليات بدات فيها قبل
ساعه من الان يعني هم الان يقوموا
يعني بفحص المبنى قبل البدء بعمليات
الانقاذ هذا شو سببه سببه كثره المواقع
المنهاره تخيلي انا التفت يعني سنتيمتر
بالكاميرا فتجدي مبنى منهار هنا ومبنى
منهار هنا ومبنى منهار هنا كبير ما هي
الاولويه واين تكمن الاولويه شعور بالذنب
بالنهايه اذا ما اكتشفوا ان هناك عائلات
ربما كان من الممكن انقاذها